this show is sponsored by naturebox
naturebox ships great tasting healthy
snacks right to your door forget the
vending machine and start snacking
smarter hold on yes i do it like this
let me do the nature box all right do it
hey everybody listen up this is this
show is sponsored by nature box okay you
want you want smart snacks if you're
hungry you can go to the vending machine
go ahead and get your high fructose
trans fat
garbage or you can break into a box in
nature with nature box you can get five
bags ten bags or twenty bags and twenty
bags normally when they ship it to your
door would cost i don't know fifty sixty
thousand dollars what do you think lee
about sixty thousand dollars
yeah exactly well guess what try 49.95
how's that sound and it's free right now
hell yeah it's free you will give you a
free if you listen to joey diaz's
podcast they will give you literally
five bags for free and they'll deliver
it to your door okay like doctors like
doctors they say like doctors codeword
joey and what would you tell them about
on it.com on it.com here's the bottom
line when it comes to on it i use their
products i use their kettlebells today
they got crazy good battle ropes look
through the catalog you get everything
there everything there is the highest
quality i am an honest user and i'll go
further i went to alaska with joe rogan
what'd i bring i brought my hemp force
protein bars and i brought my warrior
bars was i hungry the whole time never
hell no i wasn't thank you on it because
i'm on it you look at my body right you
go oh wait brian you're 47 but you play
37 right yeah you know why because i
take on it and i use their products and
you use codeword shirts to get ten
percent off yeah i used on and i ain't
getting no younger but i ain't getting
ebola either
that's how you do a commercial do you
want underwear
i want yeah you got to just read it with
feelings no no do you wear underwear
sometimes you know what you should be
wearing i'll wear a testicle center
meundies.com
the best what are those they're
tremendous they have tremendous
underwear your balls don't sweat they
have women's underwear too sexy women's
underwear me undies me underneath i
don't know about this
tremendous really on top of that the
material draws out the sweat from your
nut sack i had surgery i couldn't take a
shower that night on my knee the next
one i woke up i scratched my nut i went
to with it to expect something horrible
and they were tremendously tremendously
fresh really due to the fact i had my
undies on when i go to jiu jitsu i wear
me undies very happy it's tight by the
waist the legs cling on so your one nut
doesn't fall out of the sack you can't
beat that go to my undies.com they ship
to the united states and canada for how
much for free free cup suffer free and
free [ __ ] free nature box free free
[ __ ] and right now you get
twenty percent off of your first order
on top of the free shipping at my
understanding right now i got a european
physique so i'll be a customer very soon
that's how i would have described you
it's european i hear it all you use the
word joey remember never trust a jew
that's giving you something for free
that's what they did to g that's how
they got jesus they con the man they
have all right well then this one isn't
free then so you might know that brian
you might know that joey likes edibles
no i know that i know joey's that joey
joey is an edible connoisseur the first
thing he said when i walked in he's go
you want an edible that's right i'm
gonna eat a [ __ ] you know what you
know what else he likes he likes vapor
pens he likes favorite pens because he
smokes oil he smokes wax go to
naileditlife.com they have the best
vapor pens on the market cobra joey ds
you get 20 off you can eat that whole
thing that's a big edible and they also
make these i i already had one i'm fine
those gummies are monos they also 150
milligrams of [ __ ] death look i cut
them right down the look at those teeth
that's 13 000 at the dentist yesterday
incredible
so use code where joey is going to get
20 off of the best vapor pen on the
market and we'd like to welcome iron
dragon tv go check them out on roku they
have a ton
any martial arts movie you want to rent
they have it oh
donnie yen cha young fat
yip man the tai chi zero classics enter
the fat [ __ ] dragon tremendous go to
irondragon.com
no
irondragontv.com preston joey or church
guess what you get two movies for free
bro let me tell you something it's
amazing the joey ds podcast
perfect sponsors you got snacks you got
kung fu movies and you got edibles and
then the next morning if you want to
clean your system out you got on it
products and you got underwear and you
got underwear as well and what do they
tell you don't leave the house unless
you got clean [ __ ] underwear so we
got boo boo and a vapor pen and a vaper
pen who's better than you and we got a
little waterproof sack just case you
gotta swim to cuba
oh [ __ ]
dropping it
dropping little rick james for you crack
heads out there the churchill is
happening now
wednesday
november 12th you bad [ __ ]
slinging dick and giving out bubble gum
baby rick james old school
give me the one with lyrics [ __ ]
that's the music i [ __ ] okay
give me something with lyrics well how
about this i'm gonna give you what we
were supposed to start with and then for
the end i'll get lyrics all right you're
slipping
little classics
what else were you gonna do sit there
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] and watch tv and
scroll through the channels
the church of what's happening now
coming at you from the deaths of [ __ ]
hell tonight
north hollywood
are you kidding me or what rip out that
bong it's over it's over you gotta have
an edible either you got heroin you
might as well hit get this weekend
started early
yeah this this stuff sounds like kind of
stuff you smoke opium too brian cowan's
in the house tonight yeah baby
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
what's the story lee nothing well you've
been all day what do you mean nothing i
don't know i went to the gym had a good
day so what else is cracking like i had
jordan lee over
for record a podcast that was a lot of
fun he's a nice guy jordan lee he's a
great guy
and that's i mean that's all i did what
do you do today i did a bunch of [ __ ] i
went to jiu jitsu i drove up and down
the [ __ ] hill i took my daughter for
a walk in her little car
then i went home and almost strangled my
wife you know the regular [ __ ] day
right or wrong on a wednesday by
wednesday you want to strangle what's
the secret to making a relationship work
loving her yeah there's no love it's a
verb right
love is kind of an action right i mean
you gotta you gotta take the actions
maybe i don't know you know it's amazing
i got married when i was younger and i
didn't have an idea what marriage was
yeah
i thought it was you got married to get
laid and somebody to do your laundry and
yeah you worked all the hours in the
world well nobody teaches you that [ __ ]
right nobody there's no manual for it
right it's like you you're kind of
thrown in i read this thing about how
men and women
from
almost every culture stop playing boys
and girls stop playing with each other
about the age of six so they exclusively
play with each other like just same sex
and then by the time you're in college
that's when you shack up with a girl
maybe or even after so all of a sudden
you're living with somebody and you
haven't been spending any time unless
you've got older sisters or something
but for the most part they are aliens to
you and now you're living with them and
they think and they see the world in a
completely different way i broke up with
a girl for sleeping through raging bull
i couldn't understand why she'd sleep
through raising the ball i was like well
we don't have anything in common i'm out
but you know that doesn't make any sense
now that i know now i know how different
men and women are of course she slept
two raging bull
i broke up with a chick that she was a
drug counselor
same [ __ ] difference i'm trying to
get high she's trying to talk to me
about [ __ ] not getting hurt that's a
tough relationship right there yeah it
is that's a true story
how did you not know she was a drug
counselor yeah i knew i told her i
smoked dope that's it you know started
dating him heavy heavy next thing you
know i got dead dick
i got white rings around my nose she's
gonna notice something i'm saying that's
what she does all day
yeah it's just weird it's tough to
you got to put a lot of effort in yeah
you know you have to put a real lot of
effort and i put a lot of effort on my
wife you know and uh
i put time in at the house which is very
important you know i can't be however i
used to be a renegade who wants to be
home
no i was the same who [ __ ] wants to be
home and then you hook up with a woman
you fall in love with them and
you still have a renegade somebody i had
a guy two people tell me very valuable
advice one was they said how do you
define love i was like i don't know you
know
and he said i'll tell you how to define
love he's older than i was he said
it's love is when somebody's happiness
is more important than your own
and then he said here's another piece of
advice
uh learn how to fight
learn how to fight in other words learn
what
not to say in a fight have boundaries in
the fight you can fight you will fight
but
there's a way to fight where it causes
lasting damage
and then there's a way to fight where
you know you just apologize yeah man
you can complain but don't insult insult
yeah you know that was valuable for me
man
because i didn't know any of that
this is a girl i met wrote a play or a
she not a play she showed she sent me
the short film that she had written and
directed
and it was on a date the dude was such a
douchebag and i was like this guy's a
[ __ ] douchebag guess what that dude
was me and she based the guy not only
after me but used the lines i used on
her and i called her up and i was like
i'm sorry man i was a [ __ ] she was
like no you were just young you didn't
know
i called her a thoroughbred
i called her like i was i was it was all
about me i was talking about me the
whole time and then i was like giving
her advice on how to fix herself she was
[ __ ] smarter than i was and a better
person but there i was the know-it-all
it's amazing when you've uh
get a little older and you look back at
your relationships
and what made them fail the dumb things
you said or you did or yeah
why they left or why they didn't leave
or well i was also attracted to crazies
i was also attracted to the drug addict
in the corner track marks
you know what i mean like i like i like
damage bro i came in as the white knight
on my horse i'll fix you you're from a
good family over there now you stay over
there you're set let me check out the
chick with no father
on the pole with the track marks and the
bat tattoo to her face i'm the guy let
me fix you i'll move you into my house
i'll go to [ __ ] hell for two years
and then i'll leave
i'll leave the house with you i used to
drive rogue and crazy
he's going nuts with me pull his own
hair out he'd be like what the [ __ ] are
you doing
but whatever i had to go through my
thing
it's amazing how you uh
look back and
you were a [ __ ] like you you me i'm
talking to you you didn't do things
when you were younger
that was just
i dumped the girl because she had no mom
but it came back without me why
because it was the creepiest thing i had
ever heard in my life at that time
at that tender age of 13 i went to a
house
dying to dry humper and suck at titties
because that's all i was going to get of
course
and
i asked her where her parents went she
told me your father was like a bus
driver
and i go where's your mom she goes my
mom died at childbirth
and i couldn't even
think of swap and spit with her after
that
why
it took me about a week to go back down
there and put it behind me
and then when my mother died three years
later that's the first thing i thought
about as i was walking
to the street to call the ambulance like
that was like god punished me for
turning my back on because i didn't
understand that
i didn't comprehend how somebody could
go through life without a mother
it baffled me in the eighth grade
baffled me that she was hot this girl
was really [ __ ] hot she was irish she
had red hair she had big tits she let me
suck her neck and suck her tits in the
wintertime it takes a certain type of
woman
wintertime i'll let you suck those
titties outside in the winter and [ __ ]
in january after a basketball oh is this
in new york this is in jersey oh it's
called this i suck at tits like behind
the church
in this little fenced area in the world
she would let me suck at tits and i
would suck him for like 15 minutes and
go into this [ __ ] tit sucking thing
and then you walk home with that hard
dick
you're confused always [ __ ] horrible
and i'd walk home but during the week
i'd go over there and dry hump her yeah
and she let me dry humper and get all
red in the face and the greatest
oh my god i remember those moments so
well you do you really do get your face
first time you you finger a girl and you
and i would smell my finger i wouldn't
wash it for a long time
oh [ __ ] and i'd be like bro smell my
that's that stuff is real man when
you're a kid those smells bubble gum
and perfume and all that stuff oh the
way the smell of a woman was so
intoxicating it was beyond
i mean that sensation you chased the
rest of your life was the first person
he fell in love with a friend's mom
a friend's sister
the first girl i ever fell in love with
the first girl i ever fell in love with
was
my girl when i was 13
um
and that was in
saudi arabia but she was american
and i dated her for a year
i was the first girl but having said
that i met a girl when i was 11
for an hour at a restaurant and i there
was a picture of her that we had taken
that my parents had taken of me and her
and i used to stare at that picture
because in my mind that was the first
girl i ever loved
kids are so pure i was in love with that
girl man i mean for whatever that meant
for me in my mind it took me 15 minutes
to fall in love with that girl is that
saying i don't know who came up with it
said it takes
it takes
five minutes to fall in love love and
the rest is denial and then then there's
another saying says people get divorced
after 20 years over what they knew about
the person in the first five minutes
and i think that's i think there's a lot
of truth to that
you know yes there is that's terrible
and i think that as you get older like i
was truly in love at 14 and truly in
love at 18. there's no question about
that man i mean all in bro
all in
and by the way i'll go i'll go and and
when i was
20
same thing and then
then you start you know you start
fortifying a little bit you got a wall
you got to have you got to have some
snipers on the wall man
it's really weird the women you end up
with
at a certain time in your life
that you look back and there was no love
you ended up with them because of the
situation at hand
when
i was maybe 11 or 12 i went to miami
and i held hands with some girl
natasha and
me and my cousin talked to him and i
remember going back to new york and
looking at her picture and kind of being
in love and
talking to them on the phone until i got
the first phone bill then my mom almost
broke the [ __ ] phone over my scholars
got 200 phone bill she lived in miami
and i lived in new york in those days
there wasn't no time that's a [ __ ]
minute i was expensive and then uh
when i was 13 i was swept off my feet
totally
i mean to the point where you can't
[ __ ] focus that's right maybe 12
couldn't focus yeah and it was the scent
of a [ __ ] that drove me and i'm not
saying this in a joey diaz where i'm
saying this it wasn't even her [ __ ] it
was the scent of
that i was gonna get her [ __ ] that
drove me the perfume the smell of her
hair something something drove me crazy
and i mean guys i was always a great
student i had psychological problems and
i like to yell in class and you know we
all like to go to shop right and steal
bubble gum whatever the [ __ ] you know i
was a good kid but i never had problems
with grants like that's one thing that
that's a staple i just figured it out
early on i i translated it from not
knowing english and learning english for
myself i know you got to put work in oh
so english english is not your first
language no i'm spanish i'm a cuban so
uh
it was just really weird that i fell in
love with this girl i mean i was all in
like you said i was in i couldn't be off
the phone with her she lived across from
me you know she would come over after
school and i dry hump her i mean i
remember the first time she let me suck
at tits my stepfather found her in the
closet with no shirt on i told my mom
you know it was two families were
starting to feud
the brother didn't like me it was that
point you know and then we were forced
to break up but it was too [ __ ] late
i loved her and then i went to summer
school and i failed out of summer school
so i got left back it was [ __ ]
traumatizing until this day that i got
left back for a piece of [ __ ] like i
got left back for a while
and i remember those it's it's a
horrible feeling and that's why i turned
to basketball at that young age
but that's that was a love that that
[ __ ] held me for years you know do
you think that the death of your mother
affected how you be how you related to
women after that
i don't get to psychologically no after
that after the death of my mother
it's funny you say that because i
started relating to women as they were
gonna save me
i had two girlfriends that i basically
got pissed off at because i wanted to be
saved
i want them to hug me at night and feed
me but the problem was these two girls
were 21. they wanted to snort coke and
suck dick
so my little fantasy went out the
[ __ ] window okay they only lose you
know young [ __ ] girls yeah i was
ready to get married
at 17 after my mom died you understand
me yeah because i was ready for that
security yeah so i was waiting for a
woman to save me
and when one didn't save me i just went
on a [ __ ] day
after 84 after 21 or 22 or something i
stayed single for two or three years
until 85 yeah
i did i stayed single that those two
relationships i
i knew i wasn't going to be a
relationship type of guy i knew nobody
was going to save me unless she was 40.
yeah and she was desperate nobody was
going to [ __ ] save me so
i was like [ __ ] i'm just going to go out
there and i had a good time it was i
hooked up with a couple stories you know
you you you get the sex you need i was
never a sexual deviant i never left the
house going i'm going to go get [ __ ]
tonight no my first thing was the
addiction then if i bump into [ __ ] and
i got enough coke left over for it ah
maybe i don't you didn't you did blow
for a long time yes since i was younger
so
it really uh
then i got married then i met this broad
1985
and we got along
in hindsight that i [ __ ] love her
no
no it's such a shame it was neat yeah it
was a hole she had yes i think love like
i look back on the idea of love and it
was more or less this i need i needed to
be the one that she loved it was a
competition it was like a control factor
it was more like i just wanted to be the
dominant
uh
creature in her entire existence
so in other words like
if she was hot see i would date slippery
fish i date girls that i knew had a
history with other men
and you know they they might step out on
you i like that kind of girl because
that's a challenge that's something i
got oh i got i got a defeat and so once
i let that go
you know it was it was all right but
that was a strong force in me which was
i had to confront i didn't even do it
through therapy i never was a therapy
guy i just kind of
i don't know man i just you like dirty
[ __ ] i had a girl in 84 that was a
filthy [ __ ] animal are we best
friends today we're best friends today
she's
yeah the guy that married is a great
[ __ ] guy i love them they're on
facebook i i talk to her for
five times uh a year i see him for
chinese food when i go to jersey
but she was the type of girl that
stepped down
yeah and after we broke up years later
she stepped out with [ __ ] every i
mean but at the same time
i was getting my dick sucked i was gonna
say i've always kind of
respected a woman that wasn't hung up on
she just would follow her instincts look
man i was that way so it was very hard
for me to be a hypocrite one thing i
hate being as a hypocrite i i i no
matter how mad i am
i just try as hard as i can not to be a
hypocrite because that's the worst thing
you can be in some ways an imposter and
a hypocrite in my opinion and
you know look it's very easy to say men
and women are different usually they are
by the way but
if i step out and i'm that guy
and
i find a girl that steps out and i get
mad when she does when i've been
stepping out
it makes me a bad guy but i did get what
you think oh yeah absolutely
how dare you understand to me to me what
the
there's a better dick out there than
this guy [ __ ]
it's it's um
yeah no i didn't like the stepping out
type of [ __ ] because that should get
you killed in my world
that's you guys right glasses broke and
[ __ ] you know people go crazy
over a piece of [ __ ] i mean star rating
i have endless amount of stories that's
what picasso said
said man does everything for a woman
goes to war fights just [ __ ]
craziness yeah so now you're [ __ ]
around with a person's livelihood a
person's woman
it gets into something else and i had
that i had that's what this brought i
had this i caught it with a dude you
know but at the same time you know years
later i found out this this this is but
then again i was with all her
girlfriends it was cocaine
cocaine was disgusting and made people
suck your dick while you give them a
ride home
you know nobody did nobody did a lot of
blow and then their life happened no
nobody it was so disgusting i think of
those things now and it was that whole
town
where i came from was disgusting
because it's where in jersey north
bergen which is right by home but i know
i live in hoboken yeah yeah so it's
right next to norway in hoboken we used
to hang out in hoboken and they were all
savages yeah those jersey women those
jersey guys their [ __ ] savage
aggression in the air aggression you
know you if you ever watched your
journey fight you could fight in a
heartbeat somebody's cheating on
somebody in the jersey yeah somebody was
talking to somebody at a bar that's in
the air i that's one game i did not like
early on
i knew it gets people bit slapped and i
don't want to die over a piece of [ __ ]
and there are some tough guys those
those big
rocked out
dudes to show up at the bar and you i
would go to hoboken i'd go out this is a
90 you know 1 92. i'd go to the bar i'd
be the smallest skinniest guy in that
bar it's just everybody it's just just
big shooters galleria was the big thing
yeah i remember that i broke the door
there like three times for 400 one night
i told them guys i don't even want the
money i don't ever want to be here ever
again
because it was not for me those guys
were [ __ ] gorillas yeah what do they
do i saw one night where a guy took a
bottle broke and charged my buddy
and it was like a kung fu movie he took
it twisted them banged them cut them
with it cops came they dragged them by
their feet i thought you'd love that no
no no there was a point in my life where
i loved that there was a one point where
after i did time and [ __ ] that was it
that no no no i wasn't getting time time
cured you from that [ __ ] no wasn't that
it cured me that you see a different
dimension you see what could happen yeah
you learn on the way here i was a friend
of mine had called and said somebody had
gotten bust in jersey for drugs and i
was thinking to myself
my god what would it feel like for me to
be 51
and if i get busted for moving
seven pounds of blow or seven ounces of
blood he got caught moving seven ounces
of blow which is always a bad number
right there somebody comes through for
seven ounces something ain't right yeah
so
so what how long did you how long did
you spend the pen uh like 16 months but
this is really interesting story that
i was i was driving i was thinking about
how come i never because i told you last
week i never got pop for drugs never
before the kidnapping never and i moved
and i handled [ __ ] i was on planes with
[ __ ] i never got popular i sold coke i
never got popped for undercover buy i
knew people who were working me there's
a system they use how they work you yeah
and i remember i got popped
and when i got arrested it was the first
charge i got
okay so they were looking for me
overnight
i know i kidnapped the guy on a tuesday
at one o'clock
they were looking for me after like 11
o'clock the whole day wednesday look at
me the whole day thursday
by thursday i started calling them up
and [ __ ] with them
from two different pay phones downtown
boulder there was an albertsons and a
kmart boulder colorado boulder colorado
so they're looking for me in boulder
colorado for five felony counts oh and
it's said in the paper there's an
accomplice they're on the lookout for
i'm on lee hill road i'm where joe used
to live leo wrote up there hiding up
there in the mountains
and i finally turned myself in blah blah
blah blah so this is
i turn myself in friday at 11.
when i get to the station they try to
debrief me try to ask me a bunch of
questions i go back and forth with them
i tell them some [ __ ] they hold back
but they go listen we have a problem you
did a kidnapping
kidnapping is a frontal offense it's a
capital effect the feds are here to get
you
because at that time
there was other [ __ ] going on in boulder
some kid some kid's car
had been found in a parking garage and
it was bludgeoned with blood they never
found the body
somebody had
busted into some kid's house and he
jumped off the window and he broke both
his legs and the guy stole his blow
and now this this was a drug related
crime
so they kept saying they want a question
you say they took me down to [ __ ]
denver took me to a federal place
where i sat for four days until they
decided whether or not they were going
to press charges on me
then when they got all the
uh information it wasn't it wasn't a
kidnapping over a state line so they
they said take them back to county but
in those three days i got to uh denver
friday night late i was [ __ ] starving
and they put me in this thing and i went
and they were nice little cells you
slept by yourself but the next morning
when i came out
i started talking to two dudes there was
one dude i started talking to a white
dude he had visitation
you know uh my girl came to visit me i
went outside to talk to her and i looked
around to see who was visiting oh this
guy had his parents there they all had
diamonds on his girlfriend had [ __ ]
diamonds on so i started talking to a
bunch of people i got cozy to him
and i started asking him what had
happened
and he told me that this started two
years earlier
that he was a coke dealer you know
that's what he does for a living out of
aspen or wherever the [ __ ] he was
and he was selling blah blah blah some
guy came to him and
was he was uh
blow but he goes at the time this guy
was shooting coke
so he would come over by
a half a pound of coke and then asked me
do you mind if i blast him wow and he
blast coke blast coke blast coat and he
goes i like blasting coke that's how i
knew i gave him the [ __ ] syringe so i
started shooting with him because there
was a couple times i even shared the
[ __ ] needle with him oh [ __ ] he goes
one day the guy disappears
and nine days later i got a knock on my
door
and
i get arrested and i can't figure out
who it is and blah blah blah and i go to
the [ __ ] thing when they go to charge
me
still there's a witness he couldn't
figure out who he was
they go to the preliminary hearing it's
the [ __ ] undercover cop that's this
guy who blasted coke nine months later
and he's telling his attorney tell him
to pull up his sleeves
he goes the guy didn't even look like
him like they had run into a rehab
he goes joey i knew what was in that
thing i put the coke in there myself i
saw him blasting the [ __ ] coke in his
veins damn you know listen i know one
thing that life isn't miami vice
nobody's gonna come to lee a smart jew
who's making 20 million dollars a year
selling blow on a boat and gonna go
listen i hate to buy two blocks of coke
first of all you're gonna do a
background check
a guy like you has an attorney that runs
brian through the [ __ ] mill runs them
if anything's wrong the sick people do
you remember to live and die in l.a they
wanted the guy's luggage to make sure
his clothing said beverly hills on them
because they said they were from beverly
hills i mean they go through they should
they go through they
that's what they do if i'm going to make
a if i'm going to [ __ ] go into
business with you oh yeah you're a
friend of brian come on over i'll sell
you 55 [ __ ] keys only in miami vice
people come over and shake it up and
test it you're going to sell it to them
unless they do that [ __ ] in front of you
and [ __ ] do it and you see blood
coming out of their nose and they shot
somebody in front of you that's the only
way you're gonna i've never known
people who just sell it to you those are
the [ __ ] people get arrested do they
hire like former addicts to be or right
or just addicts to be undercover cops
because i can't imagine just a regular
guy who went to the police academy going
and shooting up cocaine well this is the
[ __ ] deal when the way to become a
good ad is to live that life yeah you
get thrown in it you're interested in
drugs and they the cops may not have
known it i mean you know you get
you have to do it when you see let me
tell you something there's nothing warm
there's nothing more [ __ ] up than when
you see him on the cover cup
yeah when you put it together you're
like god damn oh
[ __ ] he's right
so then i got transferred to boulder
and in boulder i heard all the stories
now listen anything anybody tells you in
the county jail you rip it
50 down the middle yeah but you get
paperwork a lot of people sit with you
you become friends and they show your
paperwork and they start telling you
their story and you start putting them
together one by one it's the same
[ __ ] thing
it's amazing how they put cases together
yeah
you have to come at you a couple times
to strengthen the case they're not going
to buy two answers from lee and arrest
them the first time they're going to
string them together to make the case
stronger against lee they've made
multiple buys from you
it really is no where does entrapment
fall into all that
what the feds are doing in new york city
with the terrorists
what do you mean and and and do is it
entrapment that's the other thing so i
go into a mosque
and after a week i start dropping hints
i hate [ __ ] americans
i hate [ __ ] americans i hate [ __ ]
americans americans suck dick
and listen somebody will say do you are
you correct you don't like americans yes
come tonight to the bronx to eight eight
eight eight through three it's a very
good accent and you go come tonight
games come tonight and you go to the
blanks and you have a very good voice
and they're building [ __ ] bombs how
can i trust you my friend you know and
now
you're an agent
you're in there making bombs with them
you're doing the whole thing you're
walking step by step in fact you get
closer to them by offering stuff mm-hmm
i have a friend
he works at nasa he steals the culture
he just baa boom
you know the whole that now you're close
to them i'll be honest i i i would cast
you in that role bro
so boom there you have it next thing you
know you're arresting them when they go
to blow up the car in times square
or the other things that's a different
that's entrapment but you're doing
something for the u.s right entrapment
with blowers yeah me coming to you and
going listen i know where to get 10
pounds of coke for 18 000
would you legalize blow
no you wouldn't no
why look at these morons walking around
just smoking reefer yeah
they're just smoking reef when they're
walking around like [ __ ] momos
can you imagine but but don't don't
people who want to do blow to blow
anyway it's pretty easy to get no it's
pretty easy you know
what we thought wasn't it you that said
to me in there what do you think about
the tax they're adding to sow this no
that wasn't me well i'm with adding 30
secs to talking yeah
cocaine was 100 a gram
look where it got him pablo escobar is
one of the richest men in the world not
because he sells cocaine for 28 grand
but 100 grand yeah i always say that
cocaine was the biggest marketing genius
of our time
nobody saw it coming nobody because
everything was five dollars it's an
[ __ ] for four dollars yeah you get a
nickel bag of wheat heroin was ten
dollars angel dust was fire everything
was five dollars awesome some [ __ ]
facts i think it's like
heroin
you can be an addict you can be a heroin
addict for 20 years before it devastates
your life you can be an alcoholic for 30
years before you lose everything
blow
is hard to keep going for a long time
like blow can tend to be pretty
devastating pretty quickly like if
you're doing blow all the time
i would imagine you got a three four
year window before the [ __ ] really hits
the fan wouldn't you say like it's
pretty it's hard to do much else
when you're wired the only thing i i
have whatever with you
the only disagreement i have with you is
if you do heroin for 20 years you have
no repercussions when you have any
addiction
any addiction yeah
every day you're not giving life your
all no doubt and i know this found out
my marriage now my marriage before but
let's take a look at the [ __ ] test
right first time i did a blaster blow
was october 79
a month before my mother died then i
held it off till maybe december
i started doing a bump here or bumped in
and once the 80s came i just went i was
doing everything acid
blow whatever but it was basically ass i
didn't get into coke until maybe the
winter of 80
uh 81 and that's when
blow was everywhere right you see for
weed stores now
and i was growing right with it why
because people didn't really know how
devastating it was in like 81 it was
kind of no it was still a marketing ploy
that it was what rich people did so
cocaine classy drugs right yeah cocaine
when you go last night i went to the
comedy store
and tell them the lineup that we saw
uh neil brennan sarah silverman uh who
else joe rogan
he didn't go up gerard was there after
you
uh
oh david spade was there
i mean you have these people as a
comedian when you walk into that room
yeah you get elevated yeah you get
elevated as a comic
when you did cocaine it elevated you to
the next level
when you walked out of that bathroom and
went and everybody looked at you i mean
[ __ ]
brett bread [ __ ] bread pit yeah that
[ __ ] came out of the bathroom
snorting big time with two blondes yeah
that's the dude i want to hang with you
that guy's a lot more fun yeah and girls
want to [ __ ] you it was amazing it made
you
a different person you went to a bar and
everybody wanted to talk to you and ask
you how is it and the cops weren't
coming down on that [ __ ] then no yeah
they didn't know
nobody really knew what was gonna happen
i kept that addiction going full till 85
and by the time i quit in 85 i was
[ __ ] up i was literally yeah they said
they said that the that the music
renaissance that went on in
the 60s and then carried over the 70s
with all these great rock and roll bands
and then what happened was they stopped
drinking and smoking weed and they got
into blow and they got into heroin and
that killed the music
the moms and the babas and all that you
know there was that i think it was the
hate ashbury festival the monterey rock
and roll festival and it just ended up
killing guys like you know kendricks and
janice joplin and and uh jim morrison
well wasn't weren't all like the great
70s musicians on heroin
well they that a lot of them were
because
that's according to i think what stanley
crouch was talking about the fact that
the a lot of those 70s musicians their
heroes were the black blue
singers
and and like muddy waters and those
people and a lot of those dudes had drug
issues now there was a difference
you if you had a black man in the 40s
50s 60s who was doing
heroin like bird was
like charlie parker was well uh you know
that was because
or billie holiday that was because they
were
there's a lot of things going on but you
were black there was a lot of survival
survival guilt
you were trying to overcome something
called institutionalized racism okay
so there were a lot of pressures there
were a lot of there was a lot of [ __ ]
that went on when you were black uh you
know and you couldn't vote and you were
a second-class citizen et cetera et
cetera we don't go into it but
then you had a bunch of middle-class
kids who were musically talented their
heroes were all drug addicts there was
something very cool about that so what
you had is people like janice joplin and
you had jim morrison and they were
talking like they're heroes hey man you
know you cats are all you know it was
you could hear them but they weren't
doing it very well it's very if you
actually listen to them talk they
weren't so cool they weren't like you
know the old-time jazz musicians
and they were subscribing
to
a drug problem they gave themselves a
drug problem so there was a difference
in terms of according to like you know
certain people that were talking about
there's there's a difference between
trying to overcome something like
oppression and then subscribing
to something because you want to be cool
and giving yourself a drug problem now
by the way there's another quotient to
that which is when you start doing blood
that [ __ ] feels really good and some
people just can't stop because they're
wired that way
but
one of the largest there's a guy named
nick kenner wrote a book called the dark
stuff and and he was a rock and roll
journalist and and he he
uh documents in the book how many
talented [ __ ] like lou reed
basically burned their talent out
with the wrong drugs it wasn't the weed
it was not even the booze it was the
[ __ ] blow and the heroin
that and it wasn't the acid it was the
blow and the heroin that destroyed
so many talented musicians and killed
them it's a different
angle it's a different it feeds into
somewhere different
in your heart and your soul
when you do coke the final result is
you're by yourself tony montana died by
himself yeah
yeah it's a coke isn't it it doesn't
make you a fun person to be around no
it's an and it goes
it's two the first three years you're
getting your dick sucked there's people
over you're dancing with count i love
your dog yeah yeah yeah drinking you
know oh my god we call
we doing nothing let's meet in the
bathroom do a black you know it's a fun
drug
and then you start uh pulling away
yeah and you start pulling away like
when i watch uh
um
the movie about porn with marky wahlberg
when he goes
put boogie nights boogie nights when he
goes to the guy's house
and that guy's got the chinese guy
uh yeah man you know how many
whoa he's throwing firecrackers in
places i went to four in the morning to
cop
where a guy came out and we talked to
you and meanwhile he would open the door
every 15 minutes and he'd have like
you know his brother and some other guy
[ __ ] a 16 year old girl in there
and you're waiting to get a half ounce
of coke and he's talking to you hang out
for five minutes you want a piece of ass
she's 16. we just picked her up jesus
you know when you're sitting there
you know when you start doing blow all
you want to do is go do blow and get
your dick stuck
now you're at this [ __ ] guy's house
who's got a 16 year old girl coked up
back then three guys are [ __ ]
shooting pictures with it
do you know what that feels like you
know what it feels like to i was in
beaumont texas one time
i called this guy at three in the
morning he picked me up he was gonna
take it to a [ __ ] up neighbor
and we went back then they were [ __ ]
uh those dog and [ __ ] chicken things
where they were fighting yeah you know
[ __ ] fights remember what you know it
was [ __ ] three in the morning
and there was 150 mexicans there
gambling [ __ ] and did you realize it
then that you hated it or was it just
the drugs and looking back on you like
[ __ ] that was [ __ ] up
it's it's it's [ __ ] up
you know not so long ago we were doing a
podcast at four in the morning you and i
six in the morning and i went over to
that 7-eleven on kawanga and there were
two guys and one guy was pimping a girl
out to another guy for drug money and
this is at the seventh and i'm watching
this and it brought me back to many a
years where i was just all i want to do
is get a grandma blow brian that's all i
need to do we'll sit down man this girl
is going to suck our dicks you got to
watch what the [ __ ] are you talking
about you know you know what lee kuan
yew who is the who is the long time
prime minister of singapore realized
that singapore
was in the golden triangle it was there
was burma there was you know there was
all all the opium was surrounding
singapore and lee kuan yew was like you
know
here's the thing man i want this country
to be a first world country this was a
it was a really hot swampy part of the
world and he said all right here's how
it's going to go no doubt that
everybody's going to start doing drugs
we're going to have a drug problem
because it's so easy to get so he goes
all right
if you're caught
if you're caught bringing drugs into
this country
i don't care who you are i don't care
what country you're from you're gonna
hang
you will hang
and
and there won't be a jury there will be
a judge that will look at the evidence
you hang and you hang quick
and there are so many so many stories of
like australian hitchhikers uh
backpackers come in they got a bunch of
uh opium that they wanted to sell in the
states and they were going to come to
singapore they hung
you take the the the kenyan grandmother
who who's selling blankets and trying to
sell drugs as well she hangs and they
were like to lee kuan yew they said
charlie rose said look man
you know you didn't there's no jury or
anything he said no they hang they said
but you know that seems so inhumane he
said does it we'd hang maybe four maybe
five people a year
how many lives are ruined in your
country from drugs how many children are
homeless how many children are orphaned
and he went through all the stats and i
gotta say man i was like i was like damn
the dude has a point man
if you've only got to hang five people
and a whole bunch a whole bunch of
children
have a home i mean i'm you know look i
believe in freedom so it's a difficult
thing and i think drugs probably should
be legal personally because i'm a
libertarian but i it was really
interesting to hear a benevolent
dictator which is exactly what he was
kind of talk and make a case and i was
like well i don't know i can see i can
definitely see
i can definitely see where he's coming
from in that if it's a small country
like that i don't know well i saw a
headline today that just just weed being
legal here in denver and
or
oregon it's killing mexican cartels like
their profits are way down well weed
should be legal first of all yeah of
course the idea that we'd not legal and
alcohol is is the craziest thing i've
ever heard in my life it's an old
argument but i mean you get punched in
the face by a [ __ ] alcoholic you're
not getting punched in the face by
somebody who smokes weed all the time
that's true but my mom back in boston
is in her mid-50s and every when i tell
her i smoke weed she doesn't see a
difference between that and heroin
that's because she's been brainwashed by
a movement that started a long time ago
you know that that was ignorant it was
reefer madness it was you know hemp is
bad all that stuff i mean you know
it's it's
a classic example of a misinformation
campaign but i think if you went to the
people in jail
and ruined lives because of that stuff
and i think it's [ __ ] well i think
if you went to them and said listen
that's going to get rid of the cartels i
kind of agree with you joey about
legalizing like harder stuff like heroin
and coke that seems like kind of
dangerous but for like smaller stuff i
think it it gets rid of some of the evil
listen i had a couple problems i know i
know drug addiction from a couple angles
i know drug addiction from the numbing
of pain
i know drug addiction from the uh
excitement level
i don't like [ __ ] working on movies
burned out
okay i [ __ ] hate working on a movie i
don't give a [ __ ] of jesus in the
[ __ ] movie my dick gets hard when i
go to the audition i'm right with you
baby when i go to the audition i see
three guys that are actors and i'm a
[ __ ] bummed and learn how to act at
the comedy store and i go in there and
smoke them that's it when they call me
to go do wardrobe i'm like oh this sucks
damn
insane you know how you make an acting
miserable give him a job give him a job
the same thing with blow
my whole thing with the blow
wasn't doing the blow
it was copping it oh yeah it was the
heartbeat
it was walking into that dark building
knowing nobody's gonna [ __ ] with me yeah
walking past three black guys at the
door that both of years ago i don't know
if i'm walking in that building guess
what i'm walking that building
and i'd walk to the second floor
knocking the door go in there sit down
do a blast
talk to them a little bit and walk back
out
that's what made my deck hard
getting back in the car and going back
over the gym
just the whole
thing just the whole thing
uh i was talking to somebody they were
asking me about prison they said when
you
were locked up did you have an
affiliation whenever we see people they
always have an affiliation right i never
had an affiliation i always
sleeved my way through it i was like a
snake
but i knew how you didn't gang up or any
of that [ __ ] no i knew how to satisfy
people's needs it's either money or you
hook them up in one way or the other
were you in federal or penn i was in the
state it was a statement oh sure that's
just a way to weasel your way through
life people you know we have a podcast
that's independent
everybody is pretty much mugged up with
somebody we're pretty much independent
you know one person has asked us you
know to create a monopoly i'm like no
but uh
it's still the same [ __ ] point i've
never been associated with nobody
but i had black guys that had my back
i had a couple white dudes i had my back
i had a couple italian guys had a couple
of mexican guys so it all worked out
because i worked in the kitchen i was
the stock clerk
so i had keys to a room that was off
base so you could get people's stuff i
had steroids in there and all i held
stuff so if you came to me and said i
got a pound the heroin put it under the
rice
wow they never had the dogs up there it
was like a known business everybody knew
you didn't bring the dogs to the [ __ ]
stores everybody's getting the cut
because the storage clerk runs this [ __ ]
so i would have how'd you get that gig i
had a driver's license the guy got
revoked and i moved right in i almost
blew up the kitchen
they wanted me to make cinnamon buns i
was not a baker but they made me a baker
not a [ __ ] bake and i was
making these things and they came out
like flying sausage and the kitchen
almost blew up so the guy was like i
want to quit
because they hide you that's the person
they ask you did you get hepatitis or
whatever you got hepatitis not go talk
to him they got jobs in the kitchen
so he looked at me because he's like a
baker
mr dyer so he made me a baker when i
failed as a baker
he gave me a different job like a
dishwasher
slash something and then you eat better
too right yeah you get the top [ __ ] off
the shelf but i had a driver's license
so they made me a stock clerk
combination
pick the uh the guys that you see
picking up garbage i'm the one that
would take the garbage back
to the jail okay to the count to the
to the camp george west so what i would
do is
if you ever need anything
just take a mile walk on the side of a
road
excuse me you'll be very surprised what
you find
the only people buy a grandma coke do
two bumps
and get paranoid throw the coke out the
window
so these guys would find wallets and
money
and drugs constantly they found drugs on
the side of the road on the side of the
where just died in the highway when
you're driving yeah i'm just on the side
of the road i'm going to be 15 years ago
a f a
comic came into the store from another
state
and i came in with his and they carried
something and he called me and he's like
hey man we worked together
you said if i was ever in the lake and
you hooked me up like oh sure he goes
can you get me an eight ball and i go
yeah where are you standing he told me
he was like oh you're right a couple
blocks from compadre i'll meet you there
nice kid he was like a feature actor but
his wife fed me there goes that career
hysterical
he bought the eight ball
at like 9 30 at night and i went home
this guy called me at like 11 o'clock
[ __ ] up he's like hey man you got to
pick me up i need another ball
i said i just gave you when he goes it's
a long story
and he did two bumps that he'll compadre
and he got so paranoid he threw it over
a [ __ ] fence
so he was like i need it now i need to i
got i get you another one i got him
another one he spent 500 bucks night
unbelievable and he called me again he
goes i dumped it he used to get paranoid
and dump it he dumped it what so did
when you were driving did you have a
guard in the in the van with you or the
truck no so i would pick up the garbage
so the guys would go joey i'll hide this
so i'd put it under the garbage so i
would find like an ounce up or a bag of
weed with a little weed and toilet
papers let's say i got [ __ ] blood on
it or
water it doesn't matter they would find
little uh coke bottles that were sealed
you know and they would bring them in
because they got searched so did any did
you ever try to escape or run away or
why would i because you had a van i
don't know if i was in prison i had a
van escape that's no you're never going
to stop running and then they're never
going to give you that
thing
they're never going to give you that
trust again when you get revoked from
mid-level
they'll put you in high security for now
because you try that sucks right that
sucks so wait so you were in mid-level
right because you when you get
classified they classify you by a lot of
things most importantly is were you
working at the time of your arrest what
you got arrested for you have a high
school diploma do you have a driver's
license you know there's like seven or
eight variables where you're going to
school
so when as soon as i got sentenced even
if they gave me four years
i was eligible already for a halfway
house
because of my numbers i was like a minus
one so so so with
so when when you got
murderers and rapists and all that [ __ ]
like those gangs those white aryans and
all that
those guys are in their own area they're
in their own block
they have their own little areas like
for example let's say that the guys that
hate [ __ ] uh black people and chinese
people whatever they are the aryans
right
they had a couple earrings i didn't get
along with
but there was one dude john clark that
was my motherfucker's [ __ ]
really he was tattled up this guy was
six foot four not in the best shape of
his life like he had been throughout
yeah but he lights you up and everybody
knew he was light yeah he liked me and i
liked him and he was from philly and we
played ball together he's the first
person that really started giving me
meth he would smuggle meth on mondays
and we'd have to leave the facility at
night to go to another place to play
basketball so we'd get high me and him
would do a couple of lines of [ __ ]
speed how'd he get uh math they throw
tennis balls yeah they do a bunch of
things so that was my he was my one
[ __ ] and then in the kitchen i
became friend with a murderer
his name was spencer antoine he's
probably dead now i've been [ __ ]
facebooking him and googling him and
everything can't find him murder that
guy just called out murdered somebody he
was gonna murder somebody at the camp
this guy did not play around this guy
did not play around he had like a
cockeye and he was some new orleans he
was from across the [ __ ] way from a
bad [ __ ] he was new orleans has
a big [ __ ] a long history of
murder he had murdered somebody before
and voluntary and this is the second one
yeah but he paid this [ __ ]
attorney and [ __ ] and i got him off and
[ __ ] and he used to his his name was
chicken chickenhawk antoine spencer
chickenhawk
but he would always ask me
cuba what time it is
cuba what time it is what time it is
that i always i always work in the
kitchen with you he worked in the
kitchen he was tight with the guy that
ran the kitchen and there was this big
dude from buffalo on him etchy and he
had my back so i had the black dudes and
then i had a crazy white dude that
worked in the library damn
he had murdered his wife and
her boyfriend they were cheating on him
[ __ ]
and he worked in the library this guy
was maybe five foot six
very unassuming yeah but i knew if this
[ __ ] came down he didn't say talk to
anybody but i would do acid with him wow
he didn't talk to anybody
but i would trip with him and he'd have
the keys to the library and we'd go and
then he'd show me books and [ __ ] he was
the one that told me to get into
stand-up comedy really yeah so i had and
then i had this mexican duo in there
that was a uncle nephew team
that were in there the nephew was a
[ __ ] jackoff but the uncle was a
little older and he had a burrito
business
so i told him i'd help him with the
[ __ ] burrito business he had
tremendous burritos green chili and
mashed potatoes
and in prison he had burritos yeah they
would get him smuggled i'm gonna tell
you something a lot of people don't know
about me
and here you go i don't know how many
people listen to the podcast
would you go see me on stage i'm sorry i
told the word [ __ ] around
and uh
i've never really had a gay guy come up
to me and say anything but i could see
when they shake my hand afterward and i
feel a little insecure but i'm gonna
taste them i've earned that right and
i've never told nobody a story not
because i never told it because i never
remembered it
when i got to that place
the place that you didn't hang out with
was the aids unit um aids was brand new
nobody knew about aids it was 85 and uh
yeah man people didn't know if you could
get it from like tears or i remember i
was sentenced to
to uh prison
uh
after you settled down
the first place i went to had an agent
and they had five guys in that agent
they had a black guy
who was gay and he was little dying he
was just he was losing harry they died
in a bad way before they had those
protest neighbors and [ __ ] then they had
a black dude that was like a player type
that he had it from shooting heroin it
was a mexican dude that looked just like
machete yep there was a white dude
and that was it five of them and they
had their own refrigerator their own
kitchen they had their own area
and when i got there the bookies that i
teamed up with he used to do business
with them
like he'd get them extra [ __ ] like
medication or whatever
and he told me because those people good
people and the rest of these
[ __ ] with criminal pieces of
[ __ ]
they'd treat these guys like like [ __ ]
so guess what i did one day i walked
into that [ __ ] age unit
took care of them no mask no nothing no
they walked around there was nobody
sticking there there was one guy that
slept kind of all day
but the rest of them played cards and
threw dice and listened to rap music and
[ __ ] bobby brown
and i became their friend and i brought
a kid in there from cleveland another
italian kid those mexican dudes and
pretty soon these aids guys had a
[ __ ] family
yeah you know and i didn't judge them i
knew like one or two of them might have
been gay one of them kept saying he got
it from the needle but i didn't judge
him i just remembered like i was in
prison and i felt so bad for what i had
done i wanted to do something good and i
started thinking about how i felt
sometimes being cuban when i came from
cuba and uh people staying a [ __ ] way
from the stigma to stigmatize so i went
against my grain and i hung out with
these
uh hiv guys and i got to tell you
something man i i i never talked about
this i always thought the hardest thing
about getting locked up was the holidays
and those guys made my holidays
because they cooked that that [ __ ]
kitchen looked like
better than an american kitchen
because all these aids guys had families
and all of us had families and we just
pulled all our food together you
couldn't believe it you [ __ ] couldn't
believe it there was there was nachos
and [ __ ] we're in prison we're in
[ __ ] prison there was little shrimp
cocktails and we're not the mafia you
know we're the same good friends
but they got steak slicing the garlic oh
my god i remember we had chips and the
two tvs going and that was the first
season of love and marriage yeah yeah so
we would watch that on sunday night so
in a way like your prison memories in a
way are are nice and i mean are not all
bad so if all these [ __ ] will
say oh you're a sexist you're homophobic
but listen
i was hanging out with him [ __ ]
and then back in the day before you were
born
let me tell you something i was hanging
out with hiv [ __ ] in 88 [ __ ]
with no mask and no gloves well here's
what i have just with my heart
i mean i was talking about this with the
pc army when artie lang made his
comments about you know uh carrie
champion or whatever look arty lang is a
really good person artie lang is a is
not a racist artie lang wouldn't it
doesn't have a racist bonus body he's
not and he's such a good person and yeah
his jokes were rough and maybe they were
clumsy but
i know for a fact that guy wouldn't want
to hurt anybody's feeling including that
girl uh carrie carey champion i think
her name is and i always feel like
whenever the pc army
points their guns at a guy like that or
alec baldwin for calling somebody a
[ __ ] alec baldwin called this guy
cox
guy and the the gay the gay mafia
whoever they were the extremists
basically came after him and said you're
a homophobe no he's not no he's not and
when they when they attack when they
attack people like al baldwin or rd9
that you're attacking the wrong dudes
man point your gun somewhere else yeah
if you you know those guys are on your
side you know and
for me it's like most of the people that
i know that i hang with that i really
know and that are friends of mine let
you know and people like yourself i
you're not a prejudiced person you know
you're not
you're not i you know i know very few
people who are if you're if you're that
guy who just is dumb enough to just
judge somebody on their sexuality or
their
you're a [ __ ] a-hole anyway i'm not
gonna hang with you and more importantly
you're probably a dummy so
you know i just feel like every time we
live in such a politically correct world
and you've got to be so [ __ ] careful
about what you say who what's his name
who got fire uh got suspended for two
weeks from espn for saying that such and
such address her age oh that sexist shut
the [ __ ] up
shut up we're so precious about the way
we speak people are censoring the way we
speak these these gay laws on campus are
you [ __ ] i mean uh rape laws on
campus they're trying to get people to
have verbal consent you got to say yes
if you don't say yes and you just have
sex you could accuse the guy of rape
you
talk about an infringement on on freedom
you're just jumping in there
look nobody's [ __ ] pro-rape you're
not doing anything to stop rape when you
pass laws like that you're just
infringing on freedom you're just
[ __ ] up my [ __ ] heart on that's
what the [ __ ] you're doing right because
any good people knows a freak wants to
get her hair pulled and tackled and [ __ ]
and sometimes on the way down you forget
to ask the freak do you mind if i stick
it in your armpit and [ __ ] thank you one
of the best it doesn't make you a
[ __ ] right it doesn't make you
[ __ ] rapist sometimes you get the
animal attraction
so i'm gonna stop in the middle of my
it's bad enough you gotta wear a [ __ ]
condom yeah cause your daughter might
have [ __ ] chlamydia and she [ __ ]
ten dead football not that that stopped
me i was like the [ __ ] is that yeah you
like now the kid i used to [ __ ] roll
the dice i'd be like yeah here goes
nothing oh my god were you a condom
where am i
not me i never wore a condom when i was
oh
[ __ ] away when i was 16 17 this girl
wanted to suck my dick
if i'm not i thought it was disgusting
like i just thought all that [ __ ]
no condoms are [ __ ] disgusting i'd
rather get a [ __ ] i'd rather get
something and take a shot exactly stop
and put especially when you do blow your
dick is dead all right so you got to put
a condom on when your dick is different
you got to pull over your dick and
they're going to tickle it and suck it
then it's going to grow into the condom
i don't have that type of time you got
something i don't have that type of time
if you got something looks like we both
got it [ __ ] it let's just take a chance
columbus did
i had a couple things i had some leakage
and [ __ ] i had some crabs
that's like my buddy my buddy he's a
comic and i i'll tell you his name later
no other one no no no not now and he uh
but he's he's great he goes i go he
never uses a condom i go you ever get uh
clap or anything he goes nah you get him
i've had some leakage i go the [ __ ] do
you think that is bro what do you mean
leakage
he's like 45. i'm like
pick up a medical book i remember i was
dating this girl for a while and i had
like some weird leakage
i didn't know what the [ __ ] it was but i
wasn't going to tell nobody
and when i was cooked up to the girls
and i was ready to monkey
and she had leakage and it was dry oh
monkey i just brushed that little dust
away and i got in there like a savage
don't be able to [ __ ] it's just
chlamydia whatever just some [ __ ]
take some take a seat pack your [ __ ]
[ __ ] orange juice the freshly
squeezed your back and some wheat
grasses yeah [ __ ] now they got now they
got that penicillin resistant that
antibiotic resistant gonorrhea that can
be a problem that's hard to get rid of
no i don't want none of that [ __ ] listen
i don't want none of that [ __ ] i don't
know how these people go to these
massage parlors
i would love to [ __ ] just go to like
a massage going for them to rub your
shoulders for maybe two seconds
then for them to squirt on their faces
right down over the cellophane on your
dick i hear these horrendous stories of
people doing some crazy [ __ ] right here
on the street here all over the valley
all over the place i would love to be
able to do something like that i am
paranoid yeah to the hill because i want
to get involved i don't know if there
are cameras in those rooms i don't know
what the [ __ ] going on
yes there's cameras i don't know
maybe i just don't know what to expect
i don't even know if it's a setup that's
what i worry about i go in there i see
either way my mind works is
i go in there and they got they there's
a set up and gas comes out of the fence
and i'm next thing i know i'm tied up to
a rack and they're like yeah
we got another coed another cow let's go
ahead you [ __ ] [ __ ] and that's it for
me that's my fantasy i mean that's my my
premiere my fear of my fear would you do
it like when we had the guy from the
bunny mansion i know everyone gets
tested there so you have a better chance
there of not getting something that you
do out in like the real world
but even like even that would still
scare me even though i know they're
tested just knowing that they do that
with so many people that chick they
called in and said she'll lick his nut
sack right and your [ __ ] let's say
you're in the heat of sex with the
chicken you're gonna swap spit with ely
whether she gets tested or not two hours
ago she had a [ __ ] tongue deep and
sometimes oh no yeah if you've gone that
far yeah
so if you swap and spit with it you're
gonna you're gonna swap spit one and not
think that she had a tongue up some of
these ass two hours ago well no but if i
but if you make the decision to have sex
with them you basically have given like
you've saved the bunny rants there's no
condoms no no you have to wear condoms
there but i'm just saying they get
tested but because when they came in
i've been in the body rash no but like i
was single for like a year and a half
when i moved here and when they came in
i kept thinking god that would have been
nice when i was single for that long but
like even though i know they get tested
it's still something in my brain like
anyone who has sex and it's kind of a
sexist thing too because any guy who has
sex that much other doesn't bother me at
all but just see my problem with all
that stuff is that i i just don't want
to be a dollar bill that's why i don't
like strip clubs yeah i just i just you
know i don't know man going in there and
it's a transaction
i i just i don't know it never it never
really did it for me it never really
gets me going i i'd rather i want the
girl to like me a little bit but you
said you dated strippers right yeah but
they you know that was all crazy and
passionate and nutty and believe me
there were no comments being used
why did you have a fantasy of daytona
stripper no no i had a before yeah i had
a four year run
with a stripper and it was one of the
worst experiences in my life i ended up
in jail twice i lost my clothes
and i loved it i can't lie didn't tell
you i love the juice the juice and the
the you know the thing and then one day
we both looked at each other i'm like
i'm not doing this i want to be a comic
[ __ ] say it you know see i don't i want
to be a comedian you know and uh
i look back on my life sometimes and i
think to myself there there were a lot
of people
i wish i had deleted from my life
because i would have gotten a lot of
[ __ ] done like i wasted a lot of time
trying to take care of people
dealing with their energy maybe i was
working something out i don't know i
mean i always i try to do it too much
but i do think about what i would do
differently if if i went back to being
30 or 25 i don't know i did a lot
differently
what you would do differently
it my stuff is gonna sound really weird
i mean there's no question i would have
been i would have continued to have been
a stand-up comic i think i would have
done stand-up i took a long time off
first of all i took like eight nine
years off i would not have done that
and then um i would have kept doing it
because i love it so much and i was
trying to be an actor and i look back on
and i realized that what i like more
than saying somebody else's words and
wearing somebody else's clothing
is
writing my own [ __ ]
and having that experience on stage
there's nothing like stand up in my
opinion well there's nothing like
communicating with the audience then i
probably would have boxed
earlier and i probably would have done
stuff like that but there's not a lot i
would change this i would you know i
think about stupid things like buying
real estate in venice
kind of when was jobs gotten married at
what age
i think i did that right
i took my time when did you get married
40.
it's not bad yeah it's okay because i i
i just was tired of myself i was the
center of my own universe so i wanted
children
because i don't know i mean i was
looking at my nephews and i thought to
myself you know i could easily die right
now and i would die for these kids
because they're more important than i am
like i really really meant that i
remember i was like the [ __ ] it doesn't
matter and i was like and then i was
becoming particular and peculiar about
my tastes i was becoming very
self-involved about how i had to have my
pizza how i had to have my [ __ ]
coffee and i didn't like that person i
don't want to be that [ __ ]
that anal and particular about my own
appetites i'm [ __ ] hate people like
that i want to be a little sloppy i
don't like having [ __ ] i don't like
like i don't even like being that
guarded about my own ambition
i don't i just i i just would i don't
know i don't even know how to explain
how i feel but having children for me
is a relief
i love those little kids and i like that
they put me in a position of service
of giving as opposed to taking because
that's what i was for a long time i was
the center of my own universe very easy
for a comic to be that way or someone
like me anyway
and i was a taker man but then i started
finding myself giving to shitty causes
like dating an addict and trying to fix
her and a psychologist i was friends and
said bro
you have a deep need to help
i had birds and dogs that you have a
need to nurture and help
you're doing it in the wrong way man
you're buying [ __ ] macaws
mccall's live 125 years they'll shred
your furniture they cost three thousand
dollars the dumbest [ __ ] in the world
they make more noise i was being sued by
my neighbors
you're bringing in girls who you know
have track marks the [ __ ] are you doing
either get involved in a real charity
or have children and you know i listened
so you know it's some it's
people say movies and movies or whatever
but we
we learn from movies we see different
things you see uh what's more with andy
garcia and richard gere
uh uh internal affairs at the end of
internal affairs what does richard gere
say as he's done yes great
kids yeah you know
and it's
i had a kid at 20 something
i loved that child you know somewhere
along the line everything got [ __ ] up
and we don't talk we haven't talked in
about 10 years it's it's a painful
situation but at the same time it's
about somebody trying to show a big
addict to somebody
i got a second chance
and i gotta tell you something and this
is the weirdest thing i've ever said to
anybody
once you have a child
you just don't give a [ __ ]
what used to when people come over to
you're not gonna believe sarah fell off
the wagon let that [ __ ] die that's
nothing to do with me you know it's like
i know you just lost you're putting 80
percent of luggage because
nothing matters
and all of a sudden you're like i wish i
was like this at 20 because i see this
which i saw a lot of those things
you know i i saw a lot of those
different things but now when i say it
on stage i never gave a [ __ ]
but now i really don't give a [ __ ] like
i really don't want to give a
frenchman's [ __ ] i care about her and my
wife and my wife is happy that there's
gas in the car and there's food in the
refrigerator that's what i give a [ __ ]
about anything else you're talking about
i have no idea
legalizing marijuana for blind kids so i
can play the drums listen i'll give you
three dollars you know what i'm saying i
get i'll buy a t-shirt i don't know what
to tell you you know people hit me up
all the time for [ __ ] they don't
understand your time when you have
children
they don't understand everybody just
left me a message i don't see you really
because i can't make a schedule with lee
last week lee and i were supposed to get
together for three days we finally got
together because i don't know what mood
the child's gonna be in that morning i
don't know if the baby says in the call
i'm not gonna make it today every day is
a new [ __ ] adventure and you want me
to be [ __ ] on your team to sell weed
you know to legalize weed to put an act
together what are you [ __ ] talking
about i barely have time to write jokes
that's why i go on the road to right yep
because it's three days of solitude with
a cup of coffee the tv off and you
[ __ ] write in a computer or writing
in a notebook i don't get pizza i don't
know when she's gonna kick the door down
and go
you know what the [ __ ] is on the
computer what are you watching and i
gotta stop what you're doing they don't
give a [ __ ] about twitter or myspace or
they don't give a [ __ ] you got to sit
them down and stop what you're doing
and [ __ ] put whatever they want to
watch on youtube whatever the abcs or
simple songs it changes
i have to go to jiu jitsu at 11 in
beverly hills that means i live to leave
the valley at 10.
i get her out of the house at 8 15.
you tell a kid at 9 30 on the swing we
got to go home because daddy has to go
to jiu jitsu good luck do you understand
then they're calling you what happened
to you today you told me you were coming
i got a two-year-old that [ __ ]
trumples everything yep trumps
everything that's just the way it is
you know tomorrow morning i have to
leave before she even knows what the
[ __ ] going on
i gotta leave at 8 in the morning before
she even knows what's going on
you know there's jiu jitsu at night joey
why don't you go at night you try
walking out in front of a [ __ ]
three-year-old with a bag go ahead
i dare you i dare you it's not gonna
work
so you lose all these different aspects
and you have to reschedule
there's so much learning there's so much
learning and reprogramming and what you
used to do i've learned a lot about men
and women watching my son and my
daughter interact because my son is his
destroyer my daughter is a lover my
daughter will build an entire like
dollhouse out of lego and she's got
little animals and little babies that
she's feeding and it's a whole city and
my son comes in and he's like the [ __ ]
is this you got a whole city here for no
reason and apparently you haven't heard
of godzilla he [ __ ] just destroys it
she's like ah
i like it i understand my you know it's
just funny like i have so much sympathy
for my son because i understand him as a
boy he's a linear my daughter's got 15
different emotional
levels you watch like she's six now try
figuring that [ __ ] out
she you never know how her brain works
it's just a different
it's just a different
machine my son is linear tired angry
hungry i got you i got it all i see it
right there i can read that kid like a
book my daughter is a maze a maze man
it's incredible just an emotional
creature what do you think we will know
that edible no i don't but you were
saying like you would have not taken
that break
no guys i was i'm high so i was thinking
about it like
i'm not really i'm not that spiritual
not religious but i i kind of do believe
that because i've thought about it
before would i change anything go back
and redo high school and focus more and
then go to harvard
i'm pretty happy where i am right now
well that's a good point i mean look
look
i i am my mistakes and i'll tell you
something that i that i really like to
think about
most of what is important as i get older
i guess if i could give my if i give
myself advice if i could go back and
give myself advice i'd probably say this
to myself hey
learn what not to think about there is a
law of subtraction
learning how to think is really a
process of deletion
we spend a lot of time thinking and
indulging
mentally
in areas and spaces that are not helpful
to us
we stress we worry
it's [ __ ] it's unproductive
you got to learn how it's better to
learn what not to think about when
instead of making a to-do list make a
not-to-do list you'd be amazed at how
much [ __ ] you do that ensures your own
failure
it's really important and that's what i
would say to myself if i was 20 again
i'd be like hey don't waste your time
with this [ __ ] but do you think
someone can actually
uh follow that advice without going
through it because i lost weight last
year juicing i lost a ton of weight and
i gained it all back and now i'm doing
it working out and eating healthy and i
feel like since i've learned i've gotta
say that is a
that's a different topic and that topic
is this human beings are always running
from pleasure and away from running
toward pleasure and away from pain i
think that's how you can break somebody
down there's something about eating
certain foods that you find more
pleasurable than you do painful although
the result can be more painful so i
think the way you deal with addiction
personally or you deal with food issues
or whatever it might be is you've got to
start to feel
the pleasure of
eating in a healthy way and the feeling
it gives you versus this other feeling
you've been so used to for so long
i think that's the best way to deal with
that [ __ ] they're coming for me joey
they're coming for me well you know
every time i hear a [ __ ] signal i
always think of what i did today
every time i hear a [ __ ] let me give
some shout outs to you
get the party started
my main man uh jew established 1981. i
want to thank you for drawing the
picture they're going to say it to me
mateus tovinnon
chung kennedy you bad [ __ ]
[ __ ] phillip boddy
mike lavin benji barrow
tony b back to the bone
and steve seven with cheer whatever the
[ __ ] it is
i got to talk to you about something
what's up with you lee you're all right
i'm good what are you going to eat when
you go home i'm hoping nothing and this
edible's kind of kicking in right now
what are you
feeling right
everything i don't know everything the
sun the moon yeah no i i that and that's
the thing like you can't i can't eat
when i go home because that's when the
munchies get the worst is after you
start everything tastes amazing so you
just keep getting more someone's just
gonna try to run home and hide and out
of my bedroom right on food what do you
got the house to eat today ah i got rice
cakes got goldfish a couple of rice
cakes never killed my body but it turns
into ten rice cakes especially
not peanut butter peanut butter has a
lot more calories than i thought it
would hummus
i do but not for like a snack that's
like with dinner or something
so you gotta put up but
it's a hummus on [ __ ] rice cake it's
funny when you came in tonight we're
talking about acting
i uh
from joe
and then i bumped into you in a 2001
acting seminar by the uh casting
director
of sleepers and godfather too
and uh
he also did donnie brasco what was that
[ __ ] guy's name remember
it was at ucla yeah i saw you and i
walked close to you you were talking to
two freaks
and you were in [ __ ] mid
somebody suck at my dick seminar because
those seminars are really i remember
that well
that was milton casales seminar
one milton
that was the one we did but then we did
the other one who cast godfather too oh
oh john
john that's an italian last name yes
yeah jersey yeah he grew up with donnie
brasco that's why he cast donnie brasco
he grew up with him and i went to high
school with him yeah who cast godfather
too or donny brasco or sleepers
so we're talking about soap operas and
now jane feinberg microphone vic ramos
no the casting
director gotta scroll all the way to the
bottom to get the cast director for uh
which which movie you're watching uh for
godfather too that was the casting
department no go go to go to sleepers
sleepers by the way everybody while he's
looking i'm going to be at the ontario
improv this weekend tomorrow thursday
friday saturday sunday
one night louis de giamo louis de giamas
there it is what was he doing
from jersey he cast willie cass sleepers
godfather two
uh donnie brasco he was on fire for a
while
he didn't like
lou dijamo ludigiano what about him
though you were telling the story what
were you gonna say we went for that so
go ahead where did he where would
what are you looking at i'm trying i'm
trying to find is the imdb page jesus
christ i thought you had it already
we're talking about how we went to that
uh
whatever the [ __ ] it was seminar
and how you think you're prepared for
hollywood like when you first move here
you take an acting class and you do
different things and we're talking about
jobs that you get
like my first job was
a taco bell commercial then my second
job was basketball yeah and i had no
idea what was going on i just kept then
i cast mad tv his big [ __ ]
and then i cast uh i'm going to see will
sasser right after this send him my love
yeah he's a good dude and then we uh
i cast a bunch of [ __ ] but you learn
yeah and when i first started casting
everything was high dollar production
yeah what i'm saying yeah everything uh
cbs i was stealing [ __ ] wardrobe it
was tremendous nobody nobody really
checked your wardrobe in those days
money everywhere
and
you get these jobs you know like we
talked we were comparing spider-man 2
to like the movie i did with the
director i had
paul t murray yeah boilermaker you know
where you had to fight for lunch every
day and you had a they gave you like one
serving of bread and [ __ ] and then you
do a movie like spider-man 2 where
you walk on the scene you're taking a
gallon of pomegranate juice to your room
and the [ __ ] dude there's pistachios
three different flavors
jellies
there's breakfast there's lunch you know
it's just an amazing thing
and you learn how to maneuver your way
through sets you know
i remember i got a job on general
hospital
and i remember leaving after the second
day going oh my god if i didn't have the
experience i had i would have got fired
from that job right because it moved so
fast like there's nobody holding your
hand
when you do a movie like the longest you
are we had umbrella girls
that would hold an umbrella for you
under the sun that's possible daddy kind
of so you wouldn't get a [ __ ] suntan
and they were all strippers
from the club so they went to the strip
club at night so who wants to work
tomorrow for 250 a day good times baby
you know being a smoothie girl and [ __ ]
and then when we came up when we shot
the movie in new mexico it was like a
paradise when we came to orange county
and paramount had access to us there was
no more umbrella girls there was no more
smoothie girls there was no more you
know so you learn
different things from movies like uh and
i know you've done a ton of them and
you you still do low-budget ones ever i
do
i did one last year but i may not do any
more of those they're a [ __ ]
nightmare yeah well yeah i mean you got
to pay me a lot nowadays because
otherwise it's a waste of time and let
me tell you something almost there is no
such thing as a low budget movie that
does a thing for your career it just
doesn't man give me one example
it's just an expensive student film and
you know it's very hard to make a movie
and if you're getting involved with
amateurs or people haven't done it
before i don't care how much money
they're throwing at the product it's a
[ __ ] nightmare it's gonna be a waste
of time so you know i'm focusing on
podcasting and stand up and and that's
kind of what inspires me right now
people call me all the time to off me
films and [ __ ] the last two two and a
half years and i feel lazy
but in the other hand i'm not lazy
you're just wasting my time i know the
outcome of this that's right i know i've
turned down a lot of auditions for just
episodic tv stuff because it's not going
to do a goddamn thing
i mean
it's gotta it's gotta affect
where i'm headed you know that's kind of
at this point yeah like i'm focusing on
shooting my next special and
and that kind of stuff what are you
thinking of shooting at i think down at
irvine i hope you know the new place
yeah that's why i'm doing the road so
much right now because i'm trying to
track everything yeah because you know
you got to tighten it up you know the
stuff that can be it can work really
well it's been great
and i had such a blast in tempe this
past weekend by the way thank you teddy
but you know it's like you got to always
figure out like there's stuff that'll
kill a room and stuff but then you want
to be thematic or you want to be telling
a story and i don't know man it's it's a
constant process putting a special
together is very very hard yeah very
tedious it requires a lot of work
you have to look over your material
every night if you're on stage every
night there's words that'll make a joke
just hilarious just a little exactly
so it's like a song man
it's like every bit is a rhythm there's
a rhythm and a melody to it there's a
song and and when you get the perfect
number of words and the perfect emphasis
that's when the bit is complete you know
what i mean
like it's done
and so after a while you get an hour of
that and you want to shoot that [ __ ] and
start again i want to get it out of
there yeah you started in new york i'm
sorry oh yeah
the first time i ever did stand up i
think it was 1992 man and you gave it a
break
i just wanted to be an actor and rogan
was the one who got me back in the stand
up really he was like bro what are you
doing you know just getting to stand up
and i and i you know i was like all
right in fact and and watching dane cook
too like dane cook at dublin's i was
like i want to do that he was killing me
it was really funny at the time
and uh
i just said i got to do that man i
missed it he looked like he was having
so much fun and joe used to have so much
fun i was like i know i can do that i
just gotta start doing it again
so
it's what i am bro
i think you are too oh i
i've come to the realization that
you know i grew up on movies it's how i
learned to speak english it's a part of
who i am i really enjoy watching a great
[ __ ] movie yeah
but i'm to the point where i saw behind
the curtain yeah and uh i like it it's a
good way to put it i like it but
i'll tell you what at the end of the day
unless it's a certain thing a certain
way i'm in if not pass i'd much rather
go to [ __ ] phoenix uh portland this
weekend yeah i'd much rather go to
philadelphia next week i'd much rather
go to vegas you want to philly i love
philly what are you doing
it's great yeah yeah yeah no
the city's doing that in december i
can't wait and you want to go there when
it's cold yeah i don't want to [ __ ]
around the heat in philly with humidity
i'm going i go to all those cold city
towns and i eat in the winter [ __ ] you
and all that [ __ ] wait till june i go to
buffalo in january
when that motherfucker's gotta go out
when you're on roast you're on those
beasts i'll be in boston in january
that's gonna be too cold i went into
boston last january and i literally was
waiting for the bus outside and i was
like are you [ __ ] kidding me black
boston are you doing wilbur laugh boston
are you doing dilemma yes do you do the
wilbur no i'm going back to the lab that
blossom is a good club great club and
they fixed a bunch of [ __ ] yeah they got
complaints but i didn't give a [ __ ] i
thought it was a great club they had
great food yeah packed it nice hotel
nice hotel they tried really hard you
know comedy clubs pop and go some of
them go some of them come back and some
of that temp is kicking ass when was the
last time you did tempe
last year with ireland and i'm going
back that's the only one i work i don't
want to work stand up phoenix it's too
big for me yeah and tempe is big but
it's small yeah you can get it you can
still have a race in that place yeah
i've been doing
comedy and tempe since 1990 [ __ ]
seven you know and then i went with joey
and i went by myself and
it's just you know you have roots in
these rooms then they want to pop up
another room and people like well you
can make more money at the other room it
doesn't matter i have roots in it i'm
friends with these [ __ ] walls that's
what i mean i know these walls i've been
through hours of pain through these
walls these walls i like the west palm
beach improv too
i love florida bro i love fort
lauderdale and i love the west palm
beach oh i love it how many times do you
go down it why should you i don't i go
down once a year really usually but man
it it's always packed and i have a i
have a blast i have a blog these
podcasts have opened up doors for us and
it
and the other door had opened it let
people know who we are but also let
people know what's in our heart and
what's in our mind yeah people aren't
getting up anymore and running out
unless some club owner gives out 20
tickets to like a church group do they
get up and run out people are all in now
when they go to these shows they know
who the [ __ ] you are
they know what you're going to talk
about they even have a direction where
you want them
they want you to take them that's right
it's very amazing what i've learned from
the podcast
i was on my way to being a good stand-up
comic this has made me better yeah this
podcasting has definitely made me better
doing edible with you
twice a week
has made me a better man look at the
shape of you [ __ ] i'm pretty high
what are you going to go eat fine what
are you thinking about right now you
could eat [ __ ] the diet
well tell brian where are you eating
[ __ ] the diet right now
where would you eat tonight if you could
[ __ ]
you would probably go you know what i
know i would burrito with french fries
it's nasty i was gonna go with a carne
asada fries who the [ __ ] do you think
you're dealing no exactly [ __ ]
amazing you're a sucker for those things
right over there means sucker they're
delicious what's better than french
fries with steak and guacamole i watched
that i watched that cod food special the
other night
the food show and it had fat cells
and i got to tell you something guys
that's not for me no
even when i was a fat [ __ ] and i liked
that type of food
that wasn't for me
that's never been what i liked oh really
an egg having a sandwich oh it's chicken
fingers
and what that's not for me no
you want to put a chicken parmesan
together with a little sausage in that
[ __ ] and melt the cheese and the
sauces for flavor that's old school with
some hard italian bread that i'm all in
first of all they also claim some they
also said they were one of the few
people or one of the first people that
put french fries on their sandwiches
that's a lie in west new york to new
jersey you have that [ __ ] one cuban
place where the yankees go it's been
there for 30 years georgie gets the
ticket georgie will take the 60 dollar
ticket because he goes there's nowhere
to park there's no way just probably
take the six dollars who gives a [ __ ] i
do the same just make sure i do this you
can't get paid 20 sandwiches i'll get a
i will get a [ __ ] ticket sometimes
i'm not going to deal with the park and
i'm like you know what it's worth it
what's going to cost me 65 bucks [ __ ]
[ __ ] it it's expensive it hurts me i
don't care
i'm not walking two miles
just give me the [ __ ] sandwiches yeah
i'll eat with the ticket in the
windshield like a soldier i gotta i got
in fact my meter's running out i better
run wait what meter you got no [ __ ]
meet up people down here the the meter
they want me there's no media it's
straight down here i gotta pay the
[ __ ] list oh and then i got the thing
i gotta go to one thing the thing when
they're waiting for me over there the
whole [ __ ] arena
i'm happy you came out so i'm happy
it's a pleasure having you i wish to do
yours in the next few weeks i can't wait
so let's let's do this you are you are a
true original and i so appreciate that
so please
we'll read the ads without you in here
how's that there you go all right ladies
and gentlemen come see me in ontario
ontario improv brian calling him you're
gonna be you're gonna be in uh portland
i will be in portland helium tickets are
going fast don't [ __ ] around tomorrow
night they're showing up with [ __ ]
grenades and chocolate bars some guys
showing up with two pounds of mushroom
chocolate go see joey diaz so if i was
you tomorrow you're in [ __ ] portland
don't [ __ ] around [ __ ] the rain [ __ ] the
rain jacket [ __ ] a bowler come on down
we're gonna eat some nice chocolate
mushroom come on there it is portland
portland diaz or die dieses are fine
and the week after that philadelphia you
know how we do it we ain't [ __ ]
around no more hey i'll be at the
american comedy club next weekend come
see me there [ __ ] san diego ontario
and san diego who's better than you
you're not taking another plane you're
awesome you're better than that you're
not taking no more planes the rest of
the year i got to but i'm taking a break
all right i hate playing ladies and
gentlemen
love you man lisa yeah what's your
problem what's my problem yeah what are
you sitting there giving me the evil
life for we still got another edible eat
oh no i'm not having any more edibles
listen i'm happy you guys listen to me
what'd you think lee you like this one
time yeah a little slow for you tonight
you like a little movement don't you
[ __ ] no it's good yeah
i gotta get you a little high cause now
the rest of the week you sit there with
the woman at home
watch out this is great you sit there
like a [ __ ] mooc what's what do you
got on tap this week this week i
actually have a night by myself she's
going
she's going to like a school thing and
it's only girls so i don't know what i'm
going to do friday
what do you mean she's going with school
thing that's only girls what kind of
[ __ ] is that it's like a women's
group function for what for mexican
women yeah i think so really you don't
want to go crashing you like mexican
woman i would go hide under the table
and throw a chains on the floor or
something you're
filthy little [ __ ] changed on the
floor aren't you taking her somewhere
this weekend for tamales or something
like that a cupcake class or something
didn't sign up for another class though
she signed a part it was a it's good
though you look at steak class steak
class what do they teach you how to make
steak uh duck fat potatoes
which will look good someone's
december i don't mind if you go but you
got to bring something back for the cat
and i'm saying
[ __ ] wolves here you're supposed to
be family
the church wants to i uh the church the
church wants to really welcome our new
sponsor here
irondragontv.com they're really from
nanotech
uh they sponsored tim kennedy and mike
mcdonald from the ufc i mean a great guy
i went out with him the other night to
dinner and uh really interesting
and he's got this company called
irondragontv.com
and what they do is they have uh it's a
roku channel correctly right yes and
what they have is classic kung fu movies
like tai chi zero it man series you know
classics like the enter the fat dragon
[ __ ] like that you guys are going to
love it they got life of a ninja they
got donnie yen they got young fat
what we're gonna do is this you go to
irondragontv.com we want you to try it
out let me know what you think you go to
the box and you press in joey all right
your rentals
check it out see what they got you're
gonna [ __ ] love it you're not gonna
be sorry trust me my wife already went
on it she likes the whole system how it
works
dragon tv.com go on there what's the
code word bro joey and the cool thing is
a lot of people's complaints about some
uh of the online video services is that
a lot of choices but none of them aren't
any good
these people they like martial arts
movies and that's all i have and they're
gonna have good ones it's like that's
that's sometimes the problem you get
with some of the bigger ones is they
have kind of some movies that but they
don't have like the cool stuff
and i know they're doing something with
the 4k tv oh yeah which gets released
january 1st so for the holidays or some
people already order it so i'll keep you
up to date on that but for right now go
to i tv.com preston chili get two free
rentals let's welcome them do a nice job
give them some love all right number two
on it as usual who's better than them no
you want to be in the top of your
[ __ ] game you need to get on it
whether you want the shroom tech whether
you want the hem force protein whether
you want the alpha brain all that stuff
i'm giving you 10 percent off if you go
to joeydears.net go to the on the box
and press in church church and this is
10 off on the new mct oil the coconut
oil to put in your smoothie to loosen
your bones it helps you burn fat i
haven't tried it yet i'm not going to
lie to you i'm still on the alpha brain
and the hemp protein buds it's funny
because i just finished my home protein
bars i had to get some more then we had
them in the office yeah then they sent
me a box to the house and i finished
them tremendous after a workout you
inhale one of those and it holds you off
for at least an hour until you get to
your meal i think it's 14 grams of
protein you really need 30. so eat two
of them what do you come to me for we're
[ __ ] your problems go to honor.com
right now and press in church and get 10
off your order stay on it go to the stay
on the program you get 10 off every
month and it gets delivered to the house
in the first of the month no drama no
nothing let me talk to you people about
something there's one word people love
all the time you know what that word is
free there's nothing better than the
word free why are you [ __ ] around
you're probably sitting there eating
those goldfish there's a lot of eats or
some [ __ ] cookies or something why
are you [ __ ] around go to
naturebox.com they want to offer you a
free starter package you get five bags
of delicious nutritious approved stuff
stop going to that [ __ ] potato chip
glass at your work when you get
tremendous [ __ ] snacks sent directly
to your house and guess what the first
order is free [ __ ] free free free go to
naturebox.com
and put in the box what joey slash joey
that's it yo joey that's it and you got
a box delivered to your house
immediately asap of the best tasting
snacks you've ever had in your life i
don't even charge you for shipping i
don't even charge you for shipping
that's how these [ __ ] do
whether they have the cocoa almonds or
the sriracha [ __ ] uh the pistachios
they have kettle corn
i mean whatever and every day they're
adding stuff so don't [ __ ] around now go
to naturebox.com and press in joey joey
in the box and get your free snacks sent
to your house
on the double who's better than that
again like we told this [ __ ] dude
before listen to me you're walking
around with nasty [ __ ] underwear you
got skid marks maybe you got a pimple
you popped it the bust is hanging on
your underwear you got to wash it you
didn't shout it off you don't need that
[ __ ] go to meundies.com you know how
long guys have underwear for seven years
you nasty
filthy [ __ ] do you think women
will keep their underwear for seven
years yeah some [ __ ] dirty chick in
the projects or something like that but
a natural woman they have they maintain
that [ __ ] monkey you gotta change the
underwear release stop looking at
yourself you're freaking me out
go to meundies.com right now they got a
great selection of men's and women
underwear they're sexy they fit tight
they don't slip your nuts don't fall off
the side they're tremendous underwear
comfortable i gotta pair them on right
now i'm [ __ ] floating my nut sack is
in place you haven't seen me go to move
my nuts sometimes i'm here and i'm
fidgeting that's because i don't have me
undies on because meundies keeps your
nuts in place very nice go to
meundies.com see what they got press in
the box what joey and you get 20 off
your first order and guess what they get
free shipping if you live in the united
states of canada and canada stop [ __ ]
around canada stop walking around
hitting your balls women stop walking
around separating those lips go to
bandies.com get a nice pair of undies
they keep you cool down there the
monkey's fresh everybody's happy you can
spread your [ __ ] little bat and
nobody will get a bowl that's how they
roll all right
clipboard joey also tonight what's the
code word joey all right meundies.com
code word joey get the stuff shipping
for free canada and the us now i want to
give a shout out to my main
[ __ ] these guys support me from
a to z that's why we do business with
them we love them today have a great
vaper pen out there nailgatelife.com
go to nailed it live.com and press in
joey diaz they got a selection of shirts
they got
uh vapor pens you get 20 percent off
your vape they don't [ __ ] around with
you and they ship everywhere all around
the world everybody's smoking their
[ __ ] vapor pen from finland to cyan
to before i'm making it they send them
as i am i guess so cm whatever the [ __ ]
the name of the country is it doesn't
really matter nailed it life.com
tremendous vapor pen what do you have to
press in the box
and you get 20 off your first one
usually 50 to get it for 40 hours who's
better than me i gave you honor to keep
you healthy nature bucks to keep you
strong and healthy meundies.com to keep
your [ __ ] in shape
irondragontv.com so you can watch kung
fu movies from yip man to xiaohu young
fat the the lip man series the whole
[ __ ] deal all right and then we close
up with the best vaping pet out there
nailed it life.com who's better than us
no one lee what the [ __ ] you're sitting
there like a mama luca yet beside that
it's all low but the shop i'll be in
portland this week philadelphia the week
after that and then we got a workshop
for a one-man show we're doing up at the
ice house on the 26th the night before
thanksgiving you're gonna have a great
time thank you for tuning us into your
lives thank you for being bad
[ __ ] thank you that's it
stay black [ __ ]
hey guys now that the show's over don't
forget to go to naturebox.com and sign
up to get your free sample box of great
tasting healthy snacks forget the
vending machine and start snacking
smarter with delicious treats like
barbecue corn kettle kernels go to
naturebox.com joey that's naturebox.com
joey also go to onnit.com and use
codewordchurch to get ten percent off of
any of the great products joey and brian
talked about tonight uh alpha brand new
mood swim tech immune droom tech sport
anything like that use codeword church
to get 10 off
also go to meetundies.com
joey that's meundies.com joey and check
out the pics of all the different styles
of underwear they have for men and for
the girls check out hot looking boy
shorts when you go to meetundies.com
joey you're going to get 20 off of your
first order and for a limited time right
now they're shipping for free to the
united states and canada
go to
irondragontv.com and use codeword joey
and you're gonna get two free rentals of
all of your favorite kung fu movies chao
young fat any martial art movies they
have it
use code word church i mean joey sorry
to get twenty percent off jesus christly
i was doing good until then uh and then
go to nailed it life.com really put me a
vapor pin on the market
use cobra joey diaz and you get twenty
percent off special podcast one o'clock
monday afternoon one o'clock special
podcast